the big question was how can we levy
eight people's feelings of time shortage
this feeling that there's a time famine
that they have too much to do in too
little time available and our answer to
this question turn out to be
experiencing aw so when people
experience the positive emotion of ah it
actually makes them feel they have more
time available it makes them feel more
rich in time and as a consequence of
feeling that they have more time
available it alters their
decision-making it makes them want to
experience different types of products
like experiencial goods as opposed to
material goods and you know fancy shoes
and and fancy watches they're more
likely to go out and see a movie
experiencing aw also makes people more
willing to volunteer their time to help
other people that's a very high time
cost behavior but if you feel you have
more time available you're more likely
to undertake it and also people just
seem to feel more satisfied with life
when they feel they have more time
available so ah is also able to kind of
give people a boost in life satisfaction
ah is a very powerful positive emotion
and its really made up of these kind of
two defining characteristics so the
first is that it involves perceptual
vastness now that can be something
that's physically vast in terms of
something that's you know large and size
or number but it can also be other types
of vastness like things in terms of
vastness and complexity ability or
social bearing like Fame áfourá T or
power and so this perceptual vastness is
one important component the second is
that all really involves a need for
accommodation and that's really just a
fancy way of saying it inspires a desire
to form new knowledge structures and
kind of makes you want to alter how you
understand the world you have to want to
interpret that vastness and understand
it and so that together is what makes up
an AW experience Oz ability to really
make people feel more time affluent more
rich in time is really centered on its
ability to focus people on the present
moment and this focusing on the present
moment does something really important
what it does is it slices people's
experiences up into multiple segments
and so when your experiences are kind of
full of all these different pieces it
makes you feel that more things can fit
into a unit of time it makes you feel
like your temporal resources are more
plentiful and so AHS our to really give
people this expanded perception of time
is really all about the power of the
present moment and really captivating
people's attention on what's unfolding
before them
our perceptions of time are really
biased in the direction of feeling we
have none we have no time available but
we actually have more free time than
we've ever had before we just don't feel
like it so it's really important for our
research to kind of adjust our feelings
back in line with reality and that way
we can make better decisions about what
we can actually do with our time